il ya deux choses il ya le fait de
penser que comme certaines classes
sociales éduquer jeu qui cherchent à
échapper aux touristes pour avoir un
voyage différent serait quelque chose
d'universel c'est faux c'est à dire
beaucoup beaucoup de gens le la
concentration le fait de de se retrouver
avec du monde et de pouvoir se dire
qu'on a fait du tourisme et que
d'ailleurs on est allé là où il faut
aller parce qu'il ya du monde ça fait
partie aussi des objectifs et qu en soit
il n'ya pas à les dénigrer mais
simplement il ya une partie de la
population qui en fait une petite partie
de la population occidentale sur éduqués
et socialiser au tourisme depuis
longtemps qui considère que c'est un
problème
donc du point de vue il n'ya pas à
porter un jugement de valeur par contre
ça pose un problème aux termes de
capacité de charge et là il ya un
problème c'est à dire qu'on sait qu'il
ya des cycles touristique de d'invention
des lieux de découverte
et puis ça devient des chemins des
sentiers qui deviennent des chemins puis
des routes des autoroutes
et puis à la fin ils ont peut arriver à
la rhune touristique à une réinvention
ça existe dans certains cas où
finalement on vient visiter du
patrimoine du tourisme c'est le cas
notamment par exemple de stations
thermales qui avait qui avait fermé ou
d'autres choses mais ça c'est des cycles
qu'on connaît le problème c'est à quel
moment il ya une bascule ou pas c'est ce
qui s'est passé il ya barcelone en 2000
en fait on peut on peut on sait d'après
les études qu'il ya des moments où les
politiques qui avait été fait qu'ils
utilisent et du tourisme pour faire de
l'urbain par exemple bascule à partir du
moment où les clés sont donnés aux
politiques touristiques c'est-à-dire
touristique le tourisme n'est plus un
moyen de faire autre chose de l'emploi
de l'urbain mais ça devient une finalité
donc c'est très compliqué je n'en doute
pas mais vraiment il ya une réflexion à
avoir sur cette question là et à venise
les historiens date 7 cette ville qui se
transforme pour le tourisme pour les
clients de façon encore plus antérieure
en fait plutôt au 18e ou 19e siècle donc
il ya des cycles
ça pose des problèmes non pas en valeur
ça pose des problèmes en termes de
capacité de charge d'environnements
après qu'ils aient des gens qui ont
envie de se serrer les uns les autres
sur des plages année c'est pas un
problème déontologique c'est un problème
cologix a peut être un problème social
ça peut être évidemment un problème
sanitaire en cette période
[Musique]